Andre Leon Talley is considered one of
the most influential men in fashion now
the former vogue creative director is
giving us a inside look at his more than
40 years in the industry and inside is a
word his new memoir is called the
chiffon trenches like that title he
details his life from a child in the
segregated south to becoming a high
fashion journalist Talia's worked for
Andy Warhol the Metropolitan Museum of
Art knees currently a vogue contributing
editor he joins us first on CBS this
morning gonna warn you viewers there's a
little bit of a delay and you might hear
an echo but we're glad Andre that we got
you up so let's get right to it
you said you felt it was your duty to
tell the story of a black man who
survived in the chiffon trenches you
called it a glorious and triumphant
crawl and you felt it was a big
responsibility for you you said your
blackness didn't matter what mattered
was that you were smart and smart you
were but while your blackness didn't
matter you said you also felt the sting
of racism good morning Helen thank you
for having me yes I felt my story was
very important as an epistle because
it's the story of a black man it could
be every black man who has struggled to
be calm and to be something and to make
his race to be conscious of my role as
an influential person in the fashion
industry to make my race proud of me my
blackness must therefore affirm that you
can become this unique person in a field
or the industry you can make your role
you can pave the way for future
generations did you feel pressure and
Aundre try to hold your phone perfectly
still I know this is tough did you feel
pressure being a person of color to get
this right because you were one of the
few and certainly the first I certainly
felt no pressure because I was at the
problem excuse me the top of the
mountain
I felt important I felt I had no
pressure I felt it was important to
simply represent the outstanding
excellence for the firms that I work for
for Women's Wear Daily and Vogue I said
from the front row they didn't have me
there because of the way I look they had
me there because of my knowledge and my
smartness and therefore that was an easy
role for me to play or to become because
I did have to play a role I would just
being me I was smart I was curious and I
was passionate about people yeah well
you've also said that listen you've
raised a lot of eyebrows because there's
a kids of today say you were certainly
spilling the tea as they say you are
very candid you said it's your story but
you're raising eyebrows and what what
you said about Anna Wintour who is a
queen of fashion if she's a queen you or
certainly a czar but you say about Anna
Wintour she is not capable of simple
human kindness you would love for her to
say something human and sincere to you
yet you call this a love letter to Anna
Wintour and I looked at that Andrei and
I went love letter if that's your idea
of a love letter I'm thinking I don't
want you to like me at all how do you
explain that I thought I thought that
this must be very painful for her to
read seriously well it's probably very
painful her to read it was painful me
for me to write this when I finished the
book Anna got the first galley I sent
her the galley and I said to her please
if you see anything you don't like I
will take it out of the book she called
me she compliment me and she said thank
you for saying very nice things about me
I don't want certain pages in the book
and I removed him instantly they were
spacious about a family her daughter's
wedding and her son the doctor and so
this is the painful thing for me but it
is a love letter because it's a love
letter about the joys as well as the
lows of my life and the joys of my life
have been with Anna Wintour I owe to her
the pioneering role that I had as
creative director of Vogue I was the
first black man to ever be named such I
owe that to Anna Wintour Mike I know how
much and I think in turn sorry she did
give you everything she owed me
how so she gave me opportunity she gave
me opportunity yes she did but how does
she
how does she owe you how does she owe
you yes I'm here how does Ana owe you
she owes me kindness and simple grace
and being decent when things go south I
understand changes are made in those in
the corporate institution it's vogue
when she decides that I'm no longer
working on the red carpet for the Met
Gala just call me and say Andre we're
moving in the direction you've been
wonderful I love what you're doing but
now we're going to the young influencers
who know nothing because they have 20
million followers on YouTube just say to
me it does not come no one said to me
why I was taking off the red carpet
Andre statement says Ana wishes you yes
Ana in a statement wishes you the best
that was her response she wishes you the
best where would you say your
relationship stands today because it
does seem a tad messy I think my
relationship is in an ice iceberg with
her I hope that it will not be that
forever I think it's in an iceberg with
an ice floe all right well Andre Leon
Talley I'd like to do a podcast with you
later you talked about many things being
such we abuse sexually abuse and how
that changed your life and how you're
looking for love yes you're still
looking for love I'll talk to you a
little bit later on
thank you very much Andre Leon Talley
the name of the book is thank you the
chiffon trenches is on sale tomorrow and
we'll be right back